[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight the Democratic Party has long
been a collection of deeply unhappy
interest groups that secretly hate each
other but for last three years it's been
fairly simple to keep that fractious
coalition together you just focus on
Donald Trump despising Trump jumping up
and down about how mean and vulgar and
immoral Trump is is the one thing that
pretty much every Democrat can agree on
it makes him feel virtuous so Nancy
Pelosi was hoping it would last forever
but alas election season intruded and
Democrats now have just a few months to
choose their party's nominee their
standard-bearer and that means that for
the first time in a long time they have
no choice but to focus on each other
imagine the most miserable people you
know stuck together in an elevator for
eternity that's what it's like naturally
CNN is right in the middle of it the
channels shadowy political activist
president Jeffrey Zucker has joined
forces with Elizabeth Warren in her
campaign to crush their common enemy
Bernie Sanders just before Tuesday
night's democratic debate Warren used
CNN to attack Sanders as a sexist not
sexy but sexist for saying a woman could
not be elected president Sanders denied
saying it after the debate Warren
marched over to Sanders and barked at
him presumably at Warren's request CNN
later released that tape watch how it
went including a special guest
appearance by Tom Steyer who suddenly
looks tiny and afraid
[Applause]
let's not do it right now you want to
have that discussion we'll have that
discussion you call me Alan you told me
all right good
so Elizabeth Warren is not someone you'd
want to have dinner with that much is
entirely clear
tell her you're busy if she ever calls
but what else does that video prove
well absolutely nothing not one thing
we're in the very same place we were at
the beginning of the week with an aging
unprovable allegation thrown onto the
field in desperation by a fading
presidential candidate who seems more
unlikable by the day it would get
nowhere in court but over at CNN where
being a high school student from
Kentucky is considered grounds for
character assassination
it's enough to show conclusively that
Bernie Sanders hates women
watch the analysis
[Music]
I'm sorry we pulled the wrong tape from
our feminist outrage file in fact the
real thing is even more embarrassing
watch it was so real the moment I mean
her however you want to describe it her
frustration her anger her desire to have
make this point to Bernie Sanders it was
crystal clear so you can clearly
understand her fury at that and again
it's one of those moments you don't see
very often in politics where she felt
very frustrated use whatever word you
want and she just went over to him and
told him what she was thinking I agree
with him it was for real she was pissed
off people I've heard all day are saying
well she knew she was Mike she did this
on purpose
that to me did not look like it on
purpose it looked like she was kind of
seething through that part of the debate
who do we believe like I believe
Elizabeth Warren she is feeling under
the gun where she's feeling judged as a
woman and I think that there's an
insensitivity around like her
frustration on that yeah it was totally
authentic
this time CNN tells us this time
Elizabeth Warren was being a hundred
percent completely real not like that
time she lied about her race or the time
she lied about her job history the time
she lied about her plan to finance
universal health care without a middle
class tax hike no this time for sure no
question at all Elizabeth Warren is
telling the whole truth and nothing but
and you'd have to be some kind of
misogynist to doubt her that's what they
told us all night on seeing it now why
did they tell us that why lie to us
simple the Democratic National Committee
is worried about Bernie Sanders all
those attacks on Wall Street offend
donors so Jeff Zucker
a democratic partisan who was said
repeatedly he plans to run for office
once he's finished destroying CNN jumped
in he was happy to help sucker unleashed
his army of paid robots to stop the
Bernie Menace before voters could elect
him so that's what you're watching the
media working as always as handmaidens
to the ruling class and not just on CNN
the LA Times praised Warren for refusing
to shake Sanders hand they called her
rudeness quote a master class and
handling sexism okay
but is any of this true is it real I
mean Sanders is a socialist obviously
but is he a sexist consider this
according to an analysis by Breitbart
Sanders pays his female congressional
staffers three and a half thousand
dollars more per year on average than
Elizabeth Warren does and yet according
to CNN Elizabeth Warren is the real
champion of women okay so what's the
effect of this debate well Michael Moore
isn't much of a filmmaker for that
matter much of a person but he doesn't
awful lot about the Democratic Party
watch his analysis I've known Bernie
since the 80s so there's no way he said
anything like the way it's been reported
they will mark this day January 13th as
the day donald trump was reelected oh so
trump's a beneficiary says michael moore
and by the way he may be on to something
consider that four years ago democrats
rigged the primary for hillary clinton
they did that despite the fact hillary
clinton probably would have won anyway
but they just couldn't resist cheating
because they did that because they
cheated millions of Democratic voters
emerge from the process embittered and
enraged some of them stayed home last
November others voted for Jill Steiner
Gary Johnson some moved over to Donald
Trump the net effect of this Democrats
lost they suffered a shocking upset on
Election Day could that happen again
obviously it could but no one in
Washington knows that because no one in
Washington ever learns anything